تحدث زميلي كريستيان أرماند بول
بشكل حصري مع رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي
نفتالي بينيت في وقت سابق ، أريدك فقط
أن تستمع إلى هذا التبادل
عندما يرى العالم وعندما
يرى الفلسطينيون وعندما ترى منطقتك
جنودًا إسرائيليين داخل ذلك
المسجد ،
فإنها تخلق الكثير من التوتر.  الكثير من
عدم الارتياح لماذا تسمح للجنود
الإسرائيليين بالذهاب إلى هذا المسجد ،
حسنًا أيها المسيحيون هناك تذهب مرة أخرى
لتبدأ القصة في المنتصف
ولكن الحقيقة الفعلية هي أن يوم الجمعة الماضي
في حوالي الخامسة صباحًا
دخل حوالي 300 شخص من المشاغبين الفلسطينيين إلى
جبل المعبد  مسجد
بالمتفجرات بالحجارة بدأوا في
تدنيس مسجدهم وحرقوا
رشق الحجارة ومنع حوالي
ثمانين ألف مسلم محترم من
الذهاب للصلاة.
لإرسال رجال شرطة لإزالة
مثيري الشغب ، وقد نجح بالفعل 80 ألف
مسلم ذهبوا  ثالثًا للصلاة بسلام
حتى تعرف أنه عندما تواجه العنف
عليك أن تتصرف
كوزير خارجية صارم ، أريد فقط أن
أدفعك قليلاً إلى ما
كنا نناقشه للتو ردًا
على ما سمعته للتو هناك أم
الأردن ليس كذلك
اتهامك بتشجيع الفلسطينيين أم على ارتكاب
أعمال عنف نشطة من قبل أي مشرع إسرائيلي
ولكن هذا رد فعل
الأردنيين على ما يجري والذي
يُنظر إليه على أنه
نشاط مشجع من قبل
الفلسطينيين داخل المجمع
هل هذا منطقي.
فقط أريد أن أحصل على ردكم على
ذلك بالتحديد لا ، أليس
كذلك لا معنى له؟
يجب احترام الوضع الراهن للحرم ،
وأن حرية الصلاة
للمسلمين في الحرم يجب أن تُحترم
القيود وأن الوصول إلى الحرم يجب أن
يتم رفعه
وهذا ما فعله الأردن وهذا هو و
وما فعله الأردن أيضا هو حث
الجميع أه على التأكد من أننا أه
التخفيف من أه أي
اندلاع عنف أه
بداية القصة أه بيكي هو أن أه
عندنا صراع
مستمر في التهرب من حل
عملنا من
أجله  الأشهر القليلة الماضية حتى قبل
محاولة خلق أفق سياسي من
شأنه أن يعالج قضية وجود
احتلال لا يوجد أفق
لحلها يجب أن نتحرك نحو
إنهاء كل التوترات والانتقال
إلى حل الدولتين.